news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app for free
using the link right underneath this
video
president donald trump's son-in-law and
senior advisor jared kushner
bragged in april as the country was
reopening under donald trump's direction
about how donald trump took control
back from the doctors understand
what this means here is jared kushner
bragging to bob woodward
apparently having ill-advised
conversations with bob woodward runs in
the trump family
here is jared kushner bragging about
this the last thing was
kind of doing the the guidelines which
was interesting
and that in my mind was almost like you
know it was almost like
trump getting the country back from the
doctors right in the sense that
what he now did was you know he's gonna
own the open up there were three phases
there was the panic phase the pain phase
and then the comeback phase that doesn't
mean there's not still a lot of pain and
there won't be pain for a while
but that basically was we've now put out
rules to get back to work
trump's now back in charge it's not the
doctors they've kind of
we have like a negotiated settlement
taking the country
back from the doctors during a global
pandemic we need
the doctors imagine saying we've got to
take the airplanes back from the pilots
all of these checklists and
fuel calculations and talking about what
do we do if we have to do an emergency
we gotta take control back from these
pilots we'll cut down the turnaround
time by 30 minutes each way
and we'll be able to fly an additional
flight every single day that's
essentially what they're saying here
let's take the clearing of toilet
backups
back from the plumbers my friends it's
time to get these over
confident idiot plumbers out of here
that's a phrase jared kushner will use
in this next clip
remember when they said what was it we
need a businessman running the country
like a business
well he saw himself as negotiating with
doctors
to get more deaths in exchange for some
businesses opening take a listen
the most dangerous people around the
president
are over competent idiots right because
that has a way sometimes of getting past
his defense mechanism because if you're
overconfident
then sometimes you know on a topic where
he doesn't have other people around to
kind of validate it
then he can sometimes say okay let's go
with that so that's kind of
i think if you look at the evolution
over time we've gotten rid of a lot of
the overcompetent idiots
and now he's got a lot more thoughtful
people who kind of know their place
and know what to do the most dangerous
people around trump
are over confident idiots like jared
not like the doctors instead they want
people
who know their place like for example
doctors who will let trump do whatever
he wants people like
scott atlas who is actually the epitome
of an overconfident idiot a
neuroradiologist
who was brought in to deal with an
infectious disease
but scott atlas knows his place very
revealing comments from jared kushner
and then this next one is really just
stunning it's kushner confirming exactly
what i've been saying for years
about both donald trump and his
followers it's not about
issues it's not about policy it's about
attitude
it's about pissing people off and
kushner says it listen to this
and so you know you look at like the
republican party platform it's a
document meant to like piss people off
basically
more you know it's done by activists
yeah so you have a disproportionality
between
what issues people are vocal on and
and what the people the voters really
care about and what trump's been able to
do is i
i say he basically did a full hostile
takeover of the republican party
and i don't think it's even as much
about the issues i think it's about the
attitude
just jared kushner completely laying
bare
every one of our worst suspicions about
these people and it's been obvious for a
long time
that this had happened but to hear them
say it so overtly is chilling
trump claims to be a great businessman
jared kushner a great businessman and
yet
they don't realize that the way to get
the economy back
is not to reopen prematurely it was
always
to deal with the pandemic that would
naturally fix the economy
they've never understood it and so it
just goes on and on
and now trump is endlessly repeating oh
biden wants to lock everything down
fouchy wants to lock everything down
everyone but trump wants to take away
your freedoms
but the goal isn't to lock down and
restrict freedoms it's
let's unite against the common enemy and
deal with the pandemic to save both
american lives
and to save the economy in the long term
the economy would naturally recover with
the pandemic under control and instead
this administration has said let's get
the doctors out of here
let's force openings because the focus
was
i guess short-term gains even though i
believe it has completely backfired
let's see if the election results bear
that out
and you know at the tail end of this if
you open too early
you're almost guaranteeing another
shutdown and even if it's not an
official shutdown
it's people who are going to stay home
here in massachusetts as cases have gone
from 150 a day to 300 600 1200 and now
even more
things are remaining open because it
doesn't seem there's any political
willingness to start shutting things
down
but people are staying home more and
more because they see the numbers and
that's the reality
you can't shortchange actually dealing
with the
problem and focusing only on haphazardly
fixing
uh the symptoms um but it just doesn't
work
and it's not worked and we're seeing it
now we'll continue
discussing this on the show's instagram
david pakman show
and if you're on instagram you might as
well find me on instagram at
david.pakman